don't ever speak on kanye's name again
thank you you don't speak on kanye's
name you don't speak on kanye's name you
never did archos was always true
drake lets y'all down
on jewish new year okay oh my god it's
jewish new year it's jewish it's off to
a rocky start bruh bro yes tana's
shabbat what is it how do you say it
who gives a [ __ ]
kanye is back
okay y'all are haters
you're a hater
us girls love other girls
flipping his hair
you guys told me i'm a lesbian all the
time finally i'm not gonna do it yeah
put some respect on kanye son
let's put some respect this is a it's a
podcast that respects greatness yeah
[ __ ] is a genius yeah he's a
genius genius
son
we were in the green room trying to
convince mark
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] would not take it
right how many songs we have to play son
we almost went through the whole album
who was djing even
i think it might have been smart
maybe mark was on board
exactly
he's going backward
but i think we know who wasn't on board
yay jesus what is it king what is it
called jesus king jesus is king man yay
got it bro yay got me back this week yes
let's go got me back talk about it let's
go talk about it let's go okay
it really comes down to the fact that i
have uh until this weekend no respect
for the production of music
that's really literally 70 hours ago
yeah baffled baffled by how much he
doesn't know about kanye yeah yeah yeah
i thought it was a [ __ ] casio
electric piano and you just hop on there
right and then you got beats right i've
seen scott storch make the beat live and
i'm like oh this is an especially mad
easy this is the easiest thing i've ever
seen right and then we started playing
kanye yep right whose ideas was this was
probably al's idea definitely not mark
we started playing kanye
next to clb we do one for one okay and
the production is not even close it's
not even close dude i'm telling you if
you listen on airpods to kanye the first
time you're probably like
but if you listen in a car with the [ __ ]
turned up or hear on a loud speaker then
it hits you differently it's like
this is stadium
it is
and then we started listening to it and
comparing it to like other songs
non-connie we're doing a kanye song
versus another song from just another
time right another time period like we
were playing like yeah we played slick
rick or something did we really yeah we
threw it back we were throwing back we
were going like maybe biggie [ __ ] and
like
again we're just talking about the
production we're gonna get to the bars
in a second we're just talking about the
production
obviously music has evolved right but
it is just so transparent that he is
doing something different and now i
start to understand him talking about
how i'm a genius i'm the next steve jobs
et cetera i guess musically speaking
yeah he was doing that yes i didn't
notice the difference because i'm not
you know playing them back to back yeah
right i'm just going and for me i'm more
drawn to bars yes as someone who's
literally for a living uses bars and we
know kanye's as a rapper that's how he
started we came up with kanye as a
rapper he did his own beats yeah but you
called him a rapper before he called him
a producer i knew him you always thought
i'm a producer first yeah i knew him as
a rapper first yeah i didn't know what
he was yeah the casual like nat like the
oh he's called your cat no but the
casual rap fan knew him as a rapper like
you had to be a deep cut rap dude you
know oh yeah he produced first yeah like
i didn't know about like i only knew
pharrell produced and i knew timbaland
for produce and i know swiss beat's
produced yeah he just thought of street
producers that's cool
and i found out he didn't he was just
like that sounds good yeah like when it
was like yo murder on a beat what'd you
think that was i thought that was
timberland
i thought it was timbaland pharrell or
swiss beast no there's a fourth the
asian guy that produces with pharrell
that's pharrell oh yeah that's foreign i
think pharrell yeah well consumed him
and that's why he's so young
he just absorbed the asian-ness and he
hasn't aged since i think i think that
you had those three people producing and
i really did not think there were any
other producers back in the day i knew
there were but it just didn't seem that
crazy it's three that are clearly above
everybody else okay so his production is
just on a different level yeah now
there's a bunch of trash songs on the
album there's a bunch of skips on donda
there's no question correct but
when a slapper comes on
it's clear just production we're not
talking about bars everybody at home
this you know super drake stan we're
going to get there in a second okay just
production
nothing on clb comes close yeah
close no like
you can't do it and there's a lot of
youtube comments saying like oh clb
sounds the same i don't know about that
but i did i was like oh [ __ ] kanye does
try to do different things all the time
every every album even if he misses he
does attempt to do something he takes
swings big swings and then we [ __ ] on
him for the misses but you also got to
give respect when you step back and be
like you know what he tried he tried to
do something different and he really is
much [ __ ] as he talks about trying to
change everything he's really pushing me
i don't give i don't give points for try
i give points for success so but
more often than i have respect for him
i respect i respect i just don't give
you points i'm like okay that's brave
because you got so much on the line but
if it doesn't sound good doesn't sound
good but more often than not in his
career which i think you're trying to
say also is like he's succeeded in doing
some brand new [ __ ] yeah so it's like
what if you knew my type of comedy and
all of a sudden i put out a new album as
just one-liners yeah but it was so fire
you're like oh [ __ ] that's that's that's
what comedy is now yeah and that's what
he had done musically yeah okay so i'm
going through my little hippocrates
moment right where i'm starting
and it's just so blatant it's in my face
we're listening song after song we'll
listen to [ __ ] power and we're
noticing like literally in the first
second
something happens musically in the first
second sonically something happens
you're like i need to see where this
goes yeah he grabs you by your [ __ ]
throat okay and he just yanks you down
into a sofa got it and he's like sit
down see where this goes we i wish we
could play now we get demonetized but
like i wish we could play certain songs
right now and you'll notice in the first
second yeah he's not taking his [ __ ]
time we were in the green room for
probably like two three hours i was just
kanye well uh uh
it was crazy it was four hours
the show was i think went from like
eight ended at like ten to ten and we
were there for four straight hours yeah
just playing yay and then bangers from
back in the day that we [ __ ] love and
then having fun and engaged the whole
time
the whole time and then just like having
discussion about it and like understand
what's going on again we're just talking
about production yeah right and then
also thinking about the generational
component too
listen to like college dropout you're
like oh this came out 2004. let's play
something else from 2004. and when you
do it and it's not even like in the same
league and then say the point you uh
about uh producing music back then
versus now especially back then this was
an interesting point you had to go to
the record store pull out records and
then try to find the sample on a record
player and listen to it oh [ __ ] i've
never even heard this song or like my
granddad used to play the song and now
i'm like trying to find this little
snippet or like i'm listening to the
drum break and then speeding it up and
like you had to go out and do work
nowadays and like just just to clarify
you had another system where you would
record those sounds onto yeah and then
you could take those sounds you recorded
and put them into the track that you're
building yeah you're recording onto a
tape from lego you're literally doing it
lego now everything's through the
computers and you're adding all these
you gotta go [ __ ] find the lego
pieces at the store it's not even today
lego [ __ ] where you order on amazon and
it's shipped right to you yeah it's work
doesn't it that's right i don't think
about it one song on one of kanye's old
albums where he's like oh
common skipped on his beat i turned it
into a jam like imagine how upset you
are where you take like hours and hours
making a [ __ ] beat and somebody
passes on that [ __ ] like [ __ ]
this was a week that's why he had the
ego that's why people were like he was
like yeah he's you know a piece of [ __ ]
to work with or he's real annoying it's
like dude his life yeah he was carrying
he was back and forth to the record
store yeah you know what i mean like
non-stop like buying old trash records
because there was one [ __ ] sound
again that car accident probably because
that [ __ ] was just getting home
from
yeah it's hard to make a kanye beat now
it's like next to impossible to make it
back in the day
okay so i'm starting to understand where
this ego comes from because he's like
i'm doing something that's so different
than everything else that's going on
okay
how old is kanye west that he's going to
the record story and have napster and
started mixing beats from samples from
he's making tracks in 2002. like son but
he's taking songs from the 50s 67 you
don't think those things were online by
then no
no they weren't this is why y'all get
kicked out of every country we're having
a fun [ __ ] discussion a fun [ __ ]
discussion and then you're just getting
there
you got to defend drake that's his guy
just relax okay you still got to find
even if it's
i gotta find this [ __ ] i'm downloading
it i'm protecting you guys so production
crazy we all agree yes right and
i think when i was talking to mark about
the album
we're talking about clb and like my
feeling was the album clb was better
right the whole album was better and
then mark said he goes yeah but
the
donda had higher highs yes which i
completely agree with there's some peaks
in donna but also some [ __ ] valleys
whereas clb is just kind of like across
the board pretty good
i did not feel that way we'll get but
we'll get to i want to hear your point
about it i want so but this is just
production i think we're on the same
page the dude is really good at
production i understand his ego he was
doing something was way different he was
also deciding what music was going to be
the people started kind of trying to
copy him after what he did like he truly
innovated the art i understand the ego a
little bit more now
let's talk about bars
he's a he's a bad rapper
kanye yeah yeah and truly and i wanted
he wasn't always the one i don't
understand how he got so bad i do i
don't know why i agree i i know why i i
we're listening to the songs and for me
what makes somebody a good um rapper
it's not only the skill of the rap like
the eminem has a skill yeah right he can
rap he can do the math if rap was math
he could do it better than anybody yeah
but it's how connected are you
to the bars how authentic is what you're
saying and also how aspirational is it
for the listener and aspirational
doesn't necessarily mean a boat like
when eminem was talking about like
killing his mom and [ __ ] like that
that's aspirational for a lot of like
angsty white kids they're like i want to
kill my mom too yeah [ __ ] my mom right
so when when a comedian like louis c.k
was saying [ __ ] my kids there was a lot
of parents like it's amazing people feel
it's making people connect on an
emotional level yes because of
authenticity yes right
kanye early kanye
when he was talking about his issues
with women
was authentic when he was talking about
them being either gold diggers or them
like flipping on him they didn't want to
give him some [ __ ] and then all of a
sudden they started giving some [ __ ]
his kind of like animosity for lack of a
better word to women
is very authentic and real like kanye
feels a certain way about women and it's
not surprising to me that he married kim
like he married the girl
that is how he feels about women he
feels like they're
only care about material things
like they may or may not be [ __ ] or
have sex on camera like his view of
women is the woman he ended up with
right right and anytime he's talking
about women
i mean there's a line i forget which
song it is where he talks about like the
abortions that he had
do you know what i'm talking about it's
a distinct line it's from way back but
like three of mine are in heaven right
now or something like that and it was
just like it's like a potent line right
it was truly authentic
everything else that he does
especially his recent stuff is
putting on an identity that isn't true
to him the maga hat thing isn't true
right the [ __ ] uh now i'm into
religious like yeah maybe he's into god
and that kind of stuff but it feels
forced like he's just seeking identity
because he doesn't really have an
identity because his true way to
communicate is through the music i'll
take that a little bit further it's the
part of kanye even beyond women we uh
identified with was the chip on his
shoulder he had a massive chip on his
shoulder about oh oh everybody needs to
go to college and i'm gonna drop out and
y'all think i ain't [ __ ] for it [ __ ] you
here's the entire album about why i'm
smart for not going to college and you
feel that um yo i was overlooked in the
rap game nobody want to sign me as a
[ __ ] 10-minute outro on college
dropout about his whole career that [ __ ]
you felt something kanye has to have a
chip and that chip could be applied to
women it could be applied to college it
could be applied to the rap game and
that's where you're like oh so to your
point i think i don't necessarily think
it's just women but i think you are like
oh and kanye has a chip and now he's on
top he's got his respect yeah so now
yeah exactly so like he needed the chip
he needed to be the underdog he's almost
like bernard hopkins this is a random
reference but remember when he was
boxing like he needed to be underdog and
when he became a hero it wasn't the same
yeah he needed to kind of like troll and
kanye kept saying i'm the [ __ ] goat
i'm a genius and then we were like yeah
you're the you're a genius and then he
was like [ __ ] yeah yeah what do i do
do i make you hate me so i could win you
over again maga hat yeah you know what i
mean like how do i find a way where i
can prove myself you know and um in life
of pablo everybody had counted them out
at that point a couple that we weren't
jesus i think i think probably if we
listen back now we think it was good but
a lot of people were like this ain't
good yeah and i think then he was like
[ __ ] it all right y'all counting me out
let's go
[Applause]